Welcome back, I trust you enjoyed the animation so let's unpack fear a bit
more. So in this animation we saw the invitation to change the relationship
that you have to fear. Now this is something that first begins with awareness.
If you're not aware of the way you're judging or your relationship to the
fear you're feeling then you habitually, which means it's naturally or
unconsciously, just react the way that you normally react. Now this also connects
with confidence. There were so many business leaders athletes I used to
work with where they would come in and they would have a belief that they
need to feel confident and if they don't feel confident, which means they're
feeling some type of fear or insecurity or self-doubt, if they don't feel
confident then they believe that they can't win or perform well or do their
task well because they're not feeling confident. And when I help them see that
this is actually a myth and they're all surprised because most people believe
that you need to feel confident to succeed in something and now whilst it's
good to feel confident, what I helped these leaders and athletes see is that
hundred percent evidence that there are successful people, champions, all kinds of
people doing in leadership roles, work roles, all kinds who have learned to
accept their feelings of not feeling confident and still lean in and do the
job. Now this is not to say that you go and take on a task that's dangerous and
you don't feel confident to do it. We're not talking about those situations.
We're talking about the general feeling of well I don't feel so confident or
capable for this role so I'm just gonna walk away from them. What this does is
it brings a big relief to people. Why? Because you can feel human, you can feel
not confident and still walk forward and step into the challenge in front of you
and this frees you up to grow, to expand. As we saw in the animation, Roger Ferro
was just not confident at all winning his Grand Slam title. You would think
winning a French Open Tennis Tournament is a big deal and he was just so
nervous. He was just praying the guy was gonna miss, hoping he's gonna miss, hope.
This is not really a feeling of confidence and I've shown these types
of interviews, these statements, these quotes from so many different leaders to
the clients I would work with to reassure them look you don't have to feel
confident in order to step forward and take on a challenge and grow. Now this is
really good news. Why? Because you can just embrace your feelings of whatever
you're feeling and just still lean forward and this has helped me on a
personal level tremendously. I remember there was a moment where I had to run an
online event and I was in Bali at the time when we spent a fair bit of money
promoting this event and it was actually a really terrible time during COVID and
I actually got COVID and I was sweating, I was almost hallucinating so I wasn't
feeling well but I had to run this event and I just got news that my father
had a stroke so I was emotionally not feeling good at all, I was physically
not feeling good at all, I couldn't focus properly and I had to do this event
with a large amount of people online and it was all depending on me to make
some sales and give a great experience for people attending and I remember
going through my presentation I could barely even focus on what I'm gonna say
next it was that bad. I was sweating and my voice was all broken and croaky
because I was emotionally hurting about my father more than I realized and all
this was coming out and it was terrible, absolutely terrible but because I knew
this principle I just accepted myself in a moment this is how I'm feeling and I
didn't start to panic I'm not confident oh no I'm gonna make a mistake I'm feeling
nervous because we add drama upon the initial feeling so what I did
was just accept and acknowledge what I'm feeling. If you remember back to the
above-the-line thinking model that middle section is about acceptance and
you go back above-the-line there's nothing I can do about this feeling right
now there's nothing I can do about my fear or whatever I'm feeling right now
I'm just going to lean in and continue doing my best in this moment it's so
relaxing to be able to do that I got through the event we ended up making
some sales it was okay it wasn't my best event but I was able to get through
because of this understanding about fear and confidence that I don't need to
feel good in order to do my best in that moment so there's so many wonderful
wonderful applications to changing consciously your relationship to fear
now in the animation we looked at it even in a more expansive light that in
fact when we test this out you're not going to grow as a human unless you have
tension or pressure you just not again we go back to the metaphor being in the
physical gym when you're lifting weights you're making tension on your body
that creates like blood flow and growth and you eventually get stronger
well that's what life is giving us it's giving us various tensions in different
areas in our work life and our personal life in social whatever it may be we are
we are having these challenges and that initial moment when we engage beyond our
comfort zone beyond our current skill set our beyond our current level of
comfort we're going to feel this thing that we label as uncertainty or fear this
training is all about you and I choosing how do we want to feel about that
feeling how do we want to think about that feeling and when we can see it as
expansion we can see it as the fifth stage it's going to help us grow which is
the fourth stage and we're going to have game which is the fifth stage we're
going to expand and grow beyond this moment and that is a good news and
that's exciting and if we don't feel the anxiety and fear we're either dead or
we're in our comfort zone locked in our home being all super secure so we need to
have this feeling we need to have this this challenge and therefore it's a
good thing and when we see there's a good thing then we can lean into it and not
away from it now the thing that is tricky here is that the feeling itself
doesn't feel good for most of us I would say and yet I haven't met anyone that's
told me the fear feels good and they love feeling it maybe like a adrenaline type
of junkie fear that's maybe a bit different but the general anxiety or fear
it doesn't feel good in the body it's a type of tension so if we let the feeling
dictate the meaning we're going to obviously go down in our relationship to
fear and this is where awareness comes in that's the purpose of this module this
training is to leave you with this super powerful idea that you can decide to
give the meaning that you want to give to this thing called fear and when you
give it a good meaning it becomes something as an ally it becomes your
friend and because of that it means you're going to be able to have more
power and vitality to face the various tasks so that's a look at fear now as
you progress further in the modules there's much more advanced stuff we do
unpack systematically the structure of fear fear has a structure there's
normally a worst-case scenario that sits underneath it and there's ways in which
we can remedy that and take the the dysfunctional energy out of the fear
and that's further coming up but in this module the great idea is that fear is
your ally it's your friend it's going to help you grow now I'll add more to this
because this is the deep dive now one of the things that radically empowers you to
push past the resistance of fear is one the story or the meaning you give it
which we've just covered the second thing is the why why are you doing this in
fact military intelligence understand this and there's a model called the
dip in hierarchy of attention and it starts at the very bottom where your
attention is neutral and then it goes up to something that's interesting for you
so you're going to always move from it from neutral to interesting then
something can get pleasure which can be very pleasurable for you specifically
and that's going to take your attention away from just what's interesting to
what's pleasurable and then maybe you're enjoying something pleasurable to you
but if something's important to you that you determines important your
attention is going to shift to what is important but imagine we're in a cafe
we're having this important conversation and someone comes in with a gun we're
going to shift our attention to that D danger so that's dipping now the
military intelligence understood this human model this model of human behavior
and they know that there's only one thing that can beat the fear response in a
dysfunctional way but this this negative fear that cripples you and shuts you
down and they know this because they need to send soldiers to war and the
newspapers and the media also know this that's why you have your headline
shocking disaster dangerous it gets our attention and so so the media are always
pumping out this dangerous information to get us into a fear response because
the reptilian brain need we need to survive we need to we need to know
what is this danger well the one thing that beats all of that is a mission
that's inspired something has meaning for you and it lights up a different part
of the brain that overwrites the fear response the military know this and in
their marketing campaigns when they promote recruitment it's all about
your country your patriots and make a difference and this gets someone to have
this power to be able to do something extremely difficult now you know we're
not advocating going to war here but what we are advocating is our own personal
wars with fear that cripples us or suppresses us so we want to what I call
drink from the well of wine drink from the well of wine what is your why why is
this matter why is this important and there's energy in the way the why has
power the why has vitality it has strength so sometimes when you're perhaps a
bit flat or you're feeling a bit apprehensive but you know you've got to
do this particular thing why why does this matter and try to light that up
inside of you because that's where your power source is so drinking from the
well of wine is another way to counteract the fear response that kind of
shuts you down so now in summary we've got two powerful weapons against fear and
it's not even against fear but to have to utilize fear is one is the meaning we
give fear hey it's expansion it's growth it's good it's necessary that's what I'm
feeling now okay cool I'm about to grow so now we're adding a positive meaning
which is truthful and factual in most cases some fear obviously is necessary
it's like don't go with the croc you know swimming with crocodiles or something
like that it's like hey well that's actually a fear that's intelligence and
stay away so of course there's those gap cases where fear is actually intelligent
telling you something but in the other cases where you know that you can do
this but you're feeling that tension well this is where you're about to grow as a
human being and that's a core human needs one of the six core human needs and so
that's a good thing that's number one and the second is that well what's your
why what's the reason is it worth it that's where the power is and that's why
we can go into this moment because it's worth it so there you have a team that's
fear that's the unpack of fear there's more coming up I trust you've enjoyed
this thank you for watching